congresswoman thank you thank you very
much
quoting the president yesterday you all
are people who hate our country with a
passion
you hate jewish people and you love
enemies like al qaeda
you hear those statements coming from
the president of the united states to
describe you all
and you were all lumped together and you
think what you know i think
it really kind of takes me back to what
i learned about in grade school
about i think about ruby bridges and i
think about this time
when people who advocated for the most
vulnerable
were called anti-american and i think
about the fact that
when people say this is not america
i think that america has always been a
story
and america has always been about the
triumph
of people who fight for everyone
versus those who want to preserve rights
for just a select few
and there is no
bottom to the barrel of vitriol that
will be used
and weaponized to stifle those
who want to advance rights for all
people in the united states
but i also want to remind people right
it's it's a it's a beautiful thing to
think back to
what america was and the kind of
progresses we've made
but as we think about this person making
this
speech in the white house garden you
have to remind
yourself that this is a man who spent 85
thousand dollars
and basically called for the lynching of
the exon rated five
of central park five young black men
this is a man who questioned the
american-ness
of our previous president who started
the birther
controversy our beloved first lady
still talks about how she can't forgive
him this is a man who has
deep seated animosity and hatred
who feel so small who works so hard
to make others feel beneath him
and so i think it is even ludicrous for
us to
have the space to dignify what he says
with an
answer and i just think it's really
important for us to remember as much as
we've dealt with high school bullies
elementary school bullies middle school
bullies
we're going to deal with him in that way
and
and make sure that we are not only
resisting the detrimental policies that
are coming from this administration
but we're going to do the work that the
people send us to do and
insist on pushing forth that puts
all of us forward yeah i just want to
say this i am
heartened and we all are encouraged and
grateful for
the solidarity that um that has been
offered
by our colleagues by our neighbors and
by people representing every walk of
life
since this happened but i do feel that
i'm sort of sitting
from a place of privilege that we could
have this
level of focus and attention about
[Music]
hateful tweets in the context of
you know eric garner's mother today
did not get justice from this department
of justice
we can talk about and spin out
on hate about hateful words
which are a predictable prompt
by the occupant of this white house and
i call him that
not because i don't have respect for the
oval office
not because i don't respect for the oval
office and then all the president of the
united states the occupant no because he
is only occupying the space he does not
embody the principles the responsibility
the grace the integrity of
a true president and so for that reason
i'm not dishonoring the office he does
every day he dishonors it by appealing
to the most
base part of who we are as a society
but this is very predictable
this is a distraction this is a
disruption
on our leading and legislating and
governing
on the issues of care and concern and
consequence of the american people
that they sent us here this is a
distraction from the corruption
the chaos and the callousness of this
administration how do we get here
we got here because of a policy
debate on immigration that's why we're
here
and i can tell you personally i mean i
think as soon as i heard that
it wasn't really about us i thought to
myself uh
immediately i wanted to and i put a
video out telling all the residents all
the residents in the 13th congressional
district that believed in me somebody
like myself to serve them in the co in
congress
i wanted to know they belonged i wanted
that little girl that was inspired by
all of us
uh in looking to all of us i mean young
people just driving just saying thank
you so much for running because i can
see myself in you
i want them to know that we're
unwavering
so we're not going back when you heard
the tweet that you did
did you take it seriously when you heard
it or did you think
there he goes again this is a
distraction
this is a a pivot what did you think
when you heard the tweet
for me i'm hearing about this from folks
saying did you see what the president
just said
at the same time that i'm getting text
messages from people saying rasheeda
what can we do i heard ice
is now knocking on doors without
warrants i'm trying to represent
my district this very diverse district
20 different ethnicities
and i'm trying to fight on their behalf
trying to make sure that they have a
voice here
at the same time i'm dealing with the
biggest bully i've ever had to deal with
in my lifetime
uh and trying to push back on that and
trying to do the job
that we all have been sent here to do
which is centered around the people at
home
uh this is a distraction this is a
person that
really wants to vilify demonize not only
immigrants but even communities of color
as many of my sisters here have been
talking about it is
very much a distraction getting us
unfocused
people want us focused on the policy not
this and i can tell you
not only democrats republicans are
apologizing on his behalf
people in my community who are like i
disagree with some of your policies
do you feel enough republicans have
spoken up against the president about
those
absolutely not i mean we just held a
vote today
and not a single republican could bring
themselves
no matter what their public statement or
what their public gesture
or public discomfort they could not
bring themselves
to have the basic human decency to vote
against the statement that the president
made on the floor
and when people you know when you asked
how did i feel when he tweeted that
to to pull on what rashida said it
wasn't a personal thing
it's the fact that i have been elected
and we have been elected
to united states congress to uh to
represent
between the four of us millions of
people
millions what message does it send do
you think that very few republicans
have spoken out to condemn the
president's words the normalization of
it
the fact that it's against our core
american values that they're choosing
him
over country
american society like our values are
that's rooted but i care about
the rejection the denouncing and the
condemnation
not simply from a values frame or
from a frame of being collegial because
this
is an august body a rarefied air that
we're operating and less than 12
000 people have served in the history of
congress and
we each feel i feel a deep
responsibility
to honor that but what i'm more
concerned about
are hateful and racist policies
and the impact of those policies in the
massachusetts 7th congressional district
which i represent
where in a three mile radius life
expectancy drops by 30 years
in median household income by 50 000
i'm focused on equity and justice and
that's what i was sent here to do and so
you know so were you all saying that you
were not distracted by the president's
tweets the president's actions no no and
we cannot allow
anybody to be distracted by it there is
a there is a conversation that
he gets to have on twitter that gets to
be had
uh in the oval office that turns into
policy
so when he you know haphazardly says
we should not allow muslims to we should
put a stop
uh into muslims entering this country
and everybody says oh my god what's such
a racist
statement he's islamophobic we don't pay
attention how that's connected to the
policy that he has
in literally now banning muslims but he
has a very big megaphone he's a very big
pulpit it's true but i can't muster
inflated
outrage and feigned surprise about an
act that is very consistent with who
this person has shown themselves
to be we do not have the luxury
of dedicating sweat equity and
any more mental space to the occupant
and these tweets we have to do the work
on on the issues of consequence to the
american people that people are being
choked by student loan debt
that people are rationing insulin that
people don't have
a clean drinking water and clean air
that we have a gun violence epidemic
it's interesting that you all use the
word distraction that he is
that he is trying to um he's trying to
distract away from real issues
you know it's been said about the four
of you that the four of you
are a distraction that you're a
distraction to the democratic party
that you're you're playing right into
the president's hands
that he is probably loving all of this
controversy
and this turmoil that is created what do
you say to people
and you have your critics too who say
that you all are also a distraction
that this is not how the game in
washington is played
what do you say that there are better
ways to get your message
across and make your points what do you
say
the the insinuation of that question in
itself is a distraction
because you have to think right there
are people who were saying that
the conversations between him and pelosi
was getting in the way
of her ability to negotiate with the
president and
that distraction was created by him
because he
is inept he doesn't have the ability to
negotiate and the fact that we are not
able to have
an infrastructure bill was because of
that
when we talk here and as an example
of uh how detrimental the muslim ban is
as someone who
comes from a country that is currently
on the muslim ban
or when we talk about uh his design to
try to not get
muslim refugees into this country it's
gone down 91
since 2016 to have a visual
visual representation of what muslim
americans as refugees
could achieve is is a distraction he
wants to create
when we're having a conversation about
the crisis that he's manufactured
at the border with his metering uh
policy with his family separation policy
with his
weight in mexico policy and now the kind
of humanitarian crisis
that exists in the human rights
violations that are currently
happening and the three of them go down
there and then he starts calling us
names
that's a distraction from the the
attention they are bringing
but i don't want to miss the point about
the criticism about the four of you i
don't it's not about
criticism about us i think he wants you
to focus on that
and you should be asking why is it that
we are being criticized
what is it that we bring to this body
i'll tell you what we bring
exactly we're an extension of a movement
in our country that wants medicare for
all right that wants us to unmask
incarceration that wants us to push back
against the attacks on communities of
color i mean i think all of us
have incredibly strong residents in our
district that have spoke volumes in
electing people like us
and we are a disruption to the business
as usual that it's been
washington right we were elected before
that
that each of us represent very different
districts
yes right and each of us bring our
unique and authentic
voice to this body we govern
in our own way what we are
are for women who have an alignment of
values
shared policy priorities who have
repeatedly happened to land
in the same place on the issue of
immigration
that is it there is no insurgency here
there's nothing conspiracy there is no
insurgency there is no insurgency and
there's nothing conspiratorial
what we are are four lawmakers who
happen to land
in the same place on the same issue
time and time again that are honoring
the consistency
of what we said the promises we
made that were not hollow because
the threats and the insults and assaults
the palpable fear that our districts
are living with is very real my district
is 40 percent immigrant
and i don't write a bill and i've
authored five
i don't co-sponsor legislation and i've
co-sponsored 130 bills
i don't cast a vote and i've cast dozens
of them without conferring with the
people with whom i
really answer to and that is my district
and i have the support
of my district because of the
vulnerability and the fear and the
abuses
of this of ice in our district and cbp
is the largest law enforcement agency
with the least amount of transparency
and accountability i can respect what
you're saying i think the better
question is
it's not so much your
the dispute you're having with the
president it's the
distraction the disruption that you're
having with the speaker of the house
within your own democratic party it
doesn't seem
that you are all on the same page is
that a problem
well i think and it's always been my
opinion
that in the raucous experiment of
american democracy
that dissent and discussion is an
accepted
and necessary part of our system of
governance
if we had two parties that were party
line
and every single person voted the same
exact way
and just followed commands of another
that is not in its very nature
democratic
i think that there are some people that
may say it's disruptive
but i don't think it's disruptive at all
we're doing exactly what we were sent
here to do
uh you know i i we we just had
the close of a fundraising quarter 84
of all of my donations come from small
dollar donors everyday people
you know when you say things like um the
speaker of the house as being
disrespectful to women of
color is it a is it that she's being
just
is she according to you being
disrespectful to women of color because
of your color or because
she doesn't like your policies or the
tactics that you all are taking
to make your point right and i'll
clarify uh
i did not say that she was disrespectful
of women of color
i found some of the comments
disrespectful and that was my personal
opinion
and i did feel that singling out
on the basis of one vote was
creating an opening but that doesn't
mean
that we that we fundamentally disagree
or fundamentally disrespect each other's
position
and power and ability to be here and
that's what
makes us united as a caucus but i mean
the perception
though is let me get to let me make this
point because i think it's very
important
the perception is that you were saying
that nancy pelosi
singled you all out because you were
women of color
and that you felt disrespected by that
and i think that
that personally my personal take is that
this
is part of a larger dialogue and that we
don't know
how to actually talk about race and talk
about issues and talk about dynamics in
this country
because i think it's important to to
clarify here to show
and to highlight that pointing out or
inequity does not mean that you are
calling something racist
it's pointing out an inequity but we are
so
sensitive to these things because we
don't know how to have these
conversations we don't know how to
handle these dynamics
and it creates openings for moments like
these are you speaking to the
are you speaking to nancy pelosi on
you mean right right now yeah well
you're speaking to me right now our
team but in general are you in
communication with her
our teams are are in communication our
chiefs are
but shouldn't it be a face to face
as opposed to your people in here
this is not personal i don't think that
we should personally she doesn't
wait a second with all due respect she
doesn't need protection i want to know
if you are she's the new member
not the speaker no but everyone has
every right to sit down with her in any
moment any time with any of us
she is speaker of the house she can ask
for a meeting
to sit down with us for clarification
the fact of the knowledge is and i've
done racial justice work in our country
for a long time
acknowledge the fact that we are women
of color so when you do singles out be
aware of that and what you're doing
especially because some of us are
getting death threats because some of us
are being singled out
in many ways because of our backgrounds
because of our experiences and so forth
but i think exactly interested in having
a conversation face-to-face
absolutely speaker house speaker nancy
pelosi sit down with her
yeah no absolutely and we've reached out
to that end and you've reached out to
have a meeting with her
but gail can i just say that this is a
deliberative body and i personally
would never spot or question how any of
my colleagues that's right
in their deliberation arrives at
how they will ultimately cast that vote
on the house floor
this is a representative democracy
and ultimately notwithstanding the
caucus and even our party
we were sent here on a mandate by our
districts
and when we cast those votes we cast
them alone
so i would have never questioned because
the house speaker said
you all had four votes and that's all
you had when she was talking about the
is that what you were you were offended
by i'm going to get to you in a second i
can see you're very chatty
i'm going to get to you but are you
offended because she did not
because of the way that she responded to
there was a
the vote and it was only your four votes
we are voted against that bill we are in
a democratic majority this is a huge uh
freshman class
the only class that has rivaled us in
size were the watergate babies
against a very similar backdrop of
corruption
and chaos right and so because we were
such a big caucus there is a diversity
of lived experience
of ideologies even if we are
fundamentally
bound by the same core values and for
that reason
it is a representative democracy and i
would never
question how a colleague arrives at that
vote
because if they can defend it to their
god to their conscience into their
districts
we take those votes alone congresswoman
talib
do you regret it was your first day and
you called the president of the united
states you said i'm going to we're going
to impeach that mf
do you think that that kind of language
is helpful and what did you hope would
come of that
no i mean from day one i truly believe
that he has committed impeachable
offenses
and me you know but even if you believe
that the fact that you called him
i didn't do it on the house floor and
i'm going to be unapologetic in myself
70 of americans curse i'm real this is
who i
am i'm rooted in where i come from and
it's very common for me
and for many of my residents to say
things like that but so you don't regret
experience
absolutely not i'm apologetic about it
i'm definitely definitely going to push
forward and saying
we have to impeach him but i think for
me growing up in the northern border
where i personally saw ice personally
saw i stopped people and asked them
for for their documentation where i've
seen the militarization of my community
in southwest detroit
where i mean people jogging around a
park gale
getting asked and stopping and where
i've seen
actual ice come up to schools schools
and trying to pick up parents from in
front of
a school elementary school one in front
of a daycare
for just a second let's go back to
impeachment for justice but i think that
experience needs to be
at the table why i voted against and why
you feel the way you do yes
but on paper you do not have the votes
for impeachment
on paper you don't have it so what is
the point of going through the exercise
of impeachment
when it doesn't look like it will go
anywhere the watergate class
didn't have the votes in the senate side
they didn't function from that place
they function in putting the country
first and they function on doing what's
right
yeah if that were true then we might as
well just pack it up and go home
why are we leading and legislating on
everything from gun violence prevention
to climate to consumer protection
why are we leading in legislative
legislating and moving bills out of this
house
when they are not being moved in the
senate you know this is about
our demonstrating a strength of
conviction and
acting on these issues of consequence to
the american people
how many times did senator kennedy look
to advance health care
so you know ultimately th the victory
sometimes the the
the victory is in the fight even if you
don't
win even in the official even when the
next
when the nixon impeachment began
67 something like 67 american 67
americans didn't believe in impeaching
the president
and within 10 months it was something in
the lower 20s right
so right now we're at 57 percent of
americans don't believe in impeachment
and i believe within
a few months we could probably get aoc
i've heard people say
you know you're new here shouldn't you
wait and get the lay of the land
to understand how washington works
i think one of the things that's funny i
i i'm not laughing at you i'm laughing
at the sentiment
because you've heard that sentence i'm
not the first person that said that
absolutely not but not just
me but the entire fresh freshman class
i would argue regardless of ideology was
sent here
because americans are sick of how
washington works
so why would i learn a broken playbook
where lobbyists have taken over this
place
where they influence all the bills where
we vote on things because they've how
that's how things have always been done
here americans
are not getting wage increases our
government is continuing to sow
dysfunction why would we operate
business as usual when business as usual
is not serving the public
i heard you very loud and clear
congresswoman to liber you said you were
unapologetic you were not backing down
which brings me to you congresswoman
omar
do you regret you know you you took a
lot of flack for
your comments about israel that it's all
about the benjamins do you regret that
you said that do you wish
that you had chosen your words more
carefully you're being accused of being
anti-semitic
yeah i mean regret wouldn't be the way
that i i would describe
uh what i would i think
you know oftentimes there are uh things
that
you might say might not hold weight for
you but to someone else right the way
that we hear
and consume information is very
different than how the next person uh
might
i remember talking to keith allison
about uh some words that might hold
weight
for uh black people and i said i i don't
know why that would
be offensive and he said ellen because
you're an african immigrant
you don't you don't you might not
understand um and so
we we have different i think ability
um an opportunity to learn from one
another
so you don't regret your words either i
do not but i have gotten the
i i am grateful for the opportunity to
really learn
how my words made people feel and have
taken
every single opportunity i've gotten to
to make sure that people understood that
i
i apologize for it and would you like
people to would you never really
want to clear that you were not
anti-semitic oh certainly not
yes would you like to make that clear
yes i mean and that
nothing i said at least to me
was meant for that purpose and and i
have taken i think
every single opportunity i've gotten to
make sure that people understand
that my work and one of my
responsibilities is to make sure
that we are dealing with the issue of
anti-semitism
that as i fight hard to
deal with islamophobia that i am going
to do the same thing because i
understand
that both of our communities are under
threat with
white supremacy uh and and i think it's
completely
unfair um for for that title to be
but can i say yeah i think some of the
challenges because our caucus is so big
and it's just the old adage is true and
it certainly has been my lived
experience every day that
you can't do good work if you're not in
good relationship
it is very challenging to be in good
relationship and i think
first of all i challenge people all the
time in their in their their verbage and
their word usage
to not use words like tolerance no one
wants to be tolerated
what we need to foster is understanding
and empathy and that's very challenging
you know we have
you know long intense days we work at
the end of the day
on our lines of questioning for
committee the next day
it is not an environment that is really
conducive
to fostering understanding and empathy
and building relationship and so we all
of us have to be much more intentional
about that because i think every single
member here
and i mean in the whole congress not
just in our caucus stands to learn
something from one another
i like that that that phrase i'm going
to use it i may not credit you but
okay they can't do good work without
good relationships i think that's very
important and very key
and as we sit here today there appears
to be a fractured relationship
between the squad the four of you and
nancy pelosi
do any of you think that that
relationship needs to be repaired
or that there needs to be work done to
heal that relationship
is there a fracture i don't feel a
fracture
i don't i don't i think that just like
they were
just as there were members of congress
that did not vote
for the speaker on the house floor the
day of our swearing-in
just as there are members who challenge
her
conclusions who disagree with her so do
we from time to time
but that does not mean that there is a
fundamental fracture or a dehumanizing
going on within our caucus this is
i think after eight years of a
republican majority
where they're used to the party being
lockstep no matter
how inhumane and how depraved
the the legislation they were passing
was
we're not used to a governing majority
that actually talks
and dissents and debates and disagrees
and so we think
and so because we're used to eight years
of just
following orders from the republican
caucus
when you see democrats in power and
we're actually willing to debate on
issues and say we come from different
places
we think of it as just as almost like uh
you know where
we think of it as bizarre we haven't had
eight years of the republicans so
we haven't had that well in the in in
the house and they haven't been in the
majority
okay right okay i see what you're saying
facebook has a mantra
move used to have a mantra move fast
break things
does that resonate with you all
move fast break things i mean if i don't
know about if we are breaking
the systems of oppression if we are
breaking the gridlock in washington
if we are breaking these batteries
they're nurturing no i mean i think
let's say we do want to break all of
those yeah
and then what we want to do is we want
to build a system that works for all of
us
we want to make sure that we have an
opportunity
to be in relationships with one another
we do
want to create a system that is of the
people for the people
many of the policies that we advocate
whether it is medicare for
all or cancelling out student debt or
dealing with our climate crisis
most of those policies pull at 70
percent
plus the american people are because i
know they got to go down
so we um none of us had met
i mean i had actually alex and i had met
once before
and uh we showed up at
new member orientation we were asked to
do an interview because we each
represent first
um in our in our own right right
and so we did this interview and at the
end of the interview um they said well
you all take a picture
and we took a picture just a four of you
yes because we were the
before being interviewed as first and at
the end of that interview we took the
photo
and i'm not sure who said it but just
within the context of
social media culture said oh let's just
do a hashtag
squad goals or something it was squad
goals
and then it morphed into this thing but
i said i've been saying
in the days leading up to this moment
that the reality is that anyone
to your point about it's not just about
dismantling but what we're intentional
about building
and fostering anyone who is committed to
the work of building a more equitable
and just world
is a part of the squad that's you gail
that's anyone that wants to put
in this work and and i do want to
underscore work
because in 2018 there was a lot of talk
about magic
and waves if there was a wave we didn't
ride it we created it
and i wouldn't give short shrift to our
magic what we put in here every day
is work and so anyone committed to doing
the work
of a more equitable and just world is a
part of the squad
so it's so much bigger than let's wrap
up let's let's wrap up with this
you're all new everybody pleased with
how it's going how you're playing it
you're no regrets no do-overs in your
everybody's okay with how it's going
i think yeah i'm proud of the work
you're doing i feel
good i feel immensely proud of the work
that we're doing we're sitting here you
know
in the oversight committee of the united
states congress
um ilhan doesn't sit on the committee
but but ayanna
rasheeda and my seats are right there
and from there
we have talked about and we've gotten
millions of dollars in refunds
from from federal contractors that have
been defrauding the public
we have gotten um we have gotten prep
hiv medication to go generic
we have impacted the childhood trauma we
have had the
ayanna hosted the first ever hearing in
american history in front of this
committee
in front of the oversight committee on
childhood trauma so as i listened to you
for today the squad
it doesn't sound like you're going to
change the way you do business
okay it doesn't sound like you're going
to change the way you do business
why would we this is what this is what
our district is